[Music]
hello everyone I'm Pete Olsson honest
now though I was asked to review a game
called Call of Cthulhu it is a mystery
story driven game
it has a resident evil type of feel to
it the animations on it are great the
backdrops are great the the levels are
designed beautifully the controls are
very simplistic they aren't euro one for
this weapon two for that weapon it's
more of a you have one action button you
have your regular controls and keys to
run you have a shoot button I still
haven't received a gun yet but or
something type of weapon but I did look
into the options and saw that as another
ability that I can use but it also has
different skills why after milestone
points it looks like in the game you end
up getting skill points which then can
be placed into different types of parts
of your skill tree for instance strength
or your investigation or your medicine
or your occultism or any of those types
of skills which seems to be used to
unlock different conversation paths when
you're communicating with people which
I'm assuming gives you different
outcomes closer towards the ends of the
game and it looks like even a short term
it if you don't unlock one skill or you
don't pick one skill another type of
action occurs to you and then you have
to end up doing a different set of
different set of one looking for the
path to figure out how to finish that
puzzle that you're working on which is
very neat
and the voice-acting very smooth and I
really do enjoy how Pierce's character
is and all of the other characters
around you are communicating with you it
feels genuine it feels like you're
really there there seems to be a huge
amount of replay value also with this
because you end up having those
different conversation paths so you
might not be able to attack a person and
and you can just go talk to him but you
won't see that fighting scene that you
would have if you had the combat I'm
planning on continuing to play this game
to its completion on the podcast wrist
channel and it's for the next couple of
weeks to see if we can get it completed
that I don't normally play scary games
I'm more of a first-person shooter MMO
type of individual but this scary game
isn't super scary yes I did get scared a
couple of small portions of the first
two chapters which we've already
completed and it seems pretty soon as
freaking soon free enjoyable we're only
about an hour and 20 minutes in and
we'll see we'll see how it goes from
there
so I liked everybody to say thank you
very much and hit that following
subscribe button and what we'll end up
doing is will will end up keeping you
guys up to date please check out the
channel and if you have any comments put
them below and see the iron lures
podcast which is on Sundays keep an eye
on their Twitter and I hope see everyone
good everyone soon have a good day
[Music]
[Music]
I'll be can't go anyway you got it this
way fantastic
look at the Steam the graphics on this
this is beautiful
[Music]
Suz attempt to change your nesters
what the ask
hmmm sanity
I hit spots hidden represent your
ability to find objects
the fluent those you church of our
speech strength
instigation psychology doc order please
inventory
this will affect your destiny gee you're
all so stupid what gave you the crazy
idea to come onto my turf
your turf that's news to me for a guy
who has no idea you've been doing a fair
bit of poking around my men saw you
staking out the Hawkins warehouse is
that against the law I'm no idiot
detective I'll tell you how things work
around here I decide who comes in and
who stays out and anyone who doesn't
respect my rules I punish them
is your name cat what of it maybe we can
come to an understanding maybe or maybe
not
[Music]